et la totalité des banques qui ont prêté
de l'argent à leur business sont réunis
depuis cet après midi afin de se
prononcer sur ce plan de sauvetage alors
comment en est on arrivé là le parc
accusent nous savons 21 milliards de
dettes mais la fréquentation n'est pas
en cause les explications frédérique
hovasse et de denis pagé à euro disney
on s'accroche à son siège le nouveau
déficit pour l'année 92 93 5 milliards 3
secoue les financiers en cause les
erreurs de gestion et de prévisions
dénoncé par un récent audit euro disney
a voulu calquer le modèle de gestion
pratique et adenauer et a mis trop de
temps à rectifier le tir rectifié le tir
ce fut d'abord une nouvelle politique de
prix entrée en fonction de la saison
création de forfaits avec par exemple
l'accès libre ou le transport gratuit
pour les enfants
lors de voyages organisés les
restaurants sont moins chers plus adapté
et dans tout le parc des petits camions
vendent de la nourriture à emporter les
boutiques proposent maintenant davantage
de produits disney pour les hôtels aussi
mickey a dû revoir sa copie car le taux
d'occupation global en 93 et de 55%
quasiment même que nationalement mais
très inférieur à celui de paris 72 % par
contre les hôtels économiques marche
bien occupé à 70 % c'est beaucoup mieux
que la moyenne d'île de france hors
paris mais pour la walt disney company
les hôtels ne creuse en rien leurs
déficits il invoque la conjoncture
économique les taux d'intérêt élevés
avec aujourd'hui une inflation presque
nulle douleur à milliard 7,2 frais
financiers par an pour eux il y à aussi
la crise de l'immobilier qui les a
forcés à rester propriétaire de leur
hôtel alors qu'il souhaitait les vendre
ce qui aurait permis d'éponger une
partie de leur dette et puis les clients
consomment moins que prévu les visiteurs
sont pourtant rendez-vous d'aladdin ou
d' indiana jones et les queues sont
souvent interminables mais les histoires
de picsou n'empêche pas les nouveaux
projets ni donald préparer sa nouvelle
parade pour dans dix jours car
l'objectif de roe disney est d'atteindre
un résultat net positif en 95
ok